hi I'm Nicolas me with reason TV today
we're talking with Lawson Bader he's the
president of the Competitive Enterprise
Institute CEI who have brought King V
Burwell to the Supreme Court tell us
about the case and how it came to you
the the short version is it's not a
constitutional challenge the same way
that NFIB was a couple years ago it's a
statutory interpretation which already
sounds boring frankly but what it is is
we're asking the court to interpret a
part of the original bomber care law
which essentially allowed individuals to
purchase insurance through an exchange
established and the phrases by the state
if they don't purchase through the state
then they gets the attack subsidies and
we are actually challenging IRS rule
which extended those tax subsidies to
anybody who is on an exchange right that
and so this is in that's the plurality
of states that go through there are 34
states right that shows that shows not
to set their own exchange which is I
don't think with the white house
originally expected which is probably
where they got the incentive here the
one of the arguments against the
interpretation you're pushing for is
just that come on this is clearly when
the law says it's a exchange established
by the state they meant you know either
the federal government or an individual
state and that this is kind of high you
know high comedy almost then nobody can
believe that the Supreme Court or lower
courts have taken it seriously both in
this and in a related case yeah as well
that's you know still kind of on hold so
how do you how do you respect well I
mean law says what it says and one of
the key parts is it's an exchange
established by the state in section 1311
if you go back to the section 1311 it
doesn't actually come back to a state in
with the argument the argument
essentially you're making as well
Kathleen Sebelius who was of course
health and human services secretary is
in fact a state and that's the part
that's sort of a little humor when we
when we do that the the problem is the
court needs to look at what was actually
said and you got to go back and look at
what was intended and if you go back in
the politics and remember this is before
Ted Kennedy died and all of that that's
some of the original legislative history
of Obamacare
included some of these incentives and
those did not appear in the later
version and I understand like an earlier
version did talk about it as a broader
base set of subsidies that whoever
weather was the federal government
estate and then those weren't present by
the time the final bill got past so what
what happens if you guys prevail sure in
King bee I think of this as a domino so
if we win what happens immediately is
about 5 million people in 34 states no
longer receive subsidies that's the
personal impact obviously purely from an
economic standpoint what happens is in
34 states those same individuals oh no
longer eligible of to apply to deal with
the individual mandate because and the
employer mandate is another thing that
goes away so it's all it's all linked so
employers you remember if they have one
employee who's getting a subsidy they
are actually find because of the
employer mandate I had a situation so no
employees with no subsidies no employer
mandate no fine it changes the economics
of insurance industry insurance market
essentially implodes over a couple of
years you know neither reason or CEI was
in favor of Obamacare or any you know if
anything we both I think agree that
state the state action in the health
care market needs to be shrunk not
enlarged sure part of this so
independent of that isn't part of this
case and and proceeding you know or
problems with it is that you don't
really want to pass sweeping
transformative legislation with a very
very thin majority that's all in one
party true although I would actually
argue to get the real reason we're doing
as nothing to do with Obamacare that's
just a vehicle for us real issue is does
a federal agency have the authority and
the power to essentially reinterpret and
rewrite a law passed by legislative okay
and that's the address is is good yeah i
rated no so you're saying that the IRS
is not our friend I rest well eres is
not our friend yeah this is not your
friend right it's always my friend and
but the IRS is essentially saying what
Congress passed is not what we're going
to actually interpret and now you've got
a separation power problem but then
didn't we have an NFIB I mean the case
about the individual mandate we
essentially have the Supreme Court
rewriting the law
so welcome to the wonderful world of
litigation legal interpretation and
politics in Washington DC when will we
find out whether or not you guys prevail
in this probably the end of June maybe
first week of July which is the last
week of it what's your best guess do you
think yes or no and no my best guess is
yes 54 but I'm gonna be honest that you
know it's a couple things that come up
an oral argument that mean everybody's
sort of hmmm Kennedy being on being the
key as Kennedy's always the key one but
this case it's a it's a question of
federalism that's come up and is what
the original bhama care was that
actually coercive and and is what we are
arguing coercive it of itself and that's
a bit of a twist on the federalism head
and so we'll see how Canada used that
but Roberts was silent that was the big
surprise of your arguments as Roberts
essentially said nothing of on the
merits but I think we're going to win
5-4 all right well we will leave it
there Lawson Bader president of
competitive enterprise institute thank
you so much for reason TV i'm nick
gillespie